in the shadow of downtown Manhattan lies
the place where the twin towers once
stood new office buildings spring up
nearby as the 16-acre site regenerates
the tallest one World Trade Center is
already taking shape and at the center
of that space is the 911 memorial
opening to the public for the first time
on the twelfth of September we are
sending exactly where the tower one
stood in fact this his design chosen
from over 5,000 submission of optic
Michael Arad is the man responsible for
transforming a place synonymous with
horror and loss into a fitting tribute
to those who died in the attacks but
when those attacks occurred I became in
New York Renison I felt this connection
in kinship and and I hope that this
Memorial Plaza will do the same for New
Yorkers when they come here to the side
they might come here alone but not be
here alone oak trees have been planted
to fill the plaza and the names of the
nearly 3,000 people who died will be
inscribed in bronze around the edges of
the pools marking the footprint of each
tower although it is still covered up
Paula Barry knows the name of her
husband David is here next to those of
his colleagues who all died when the
south tower fell she helped to advise
the designers as the memorial was built
for her a painful process you know
everyone talks about the sense of
closure I feel I don't feel that and I
don't think I ever will I hope it will
be therapeutic because I think we are
all still very much scarred by the
experience
the somme the site will never be a place
of healing a group of families are upset
that it's museum due to open in a year
plans to privately house the
unidentified remains of over a thousand
victims others say they haven't been
consulted enough as the memorial
developed Michael Arad knows he cannot
please everyone this is such an
emotionally charged project and you have
to not let go that emotional connection
to it but you can't let Daddy hinder you
or hamper your leader however difficult
the job what was once a twisted pile of
steel and rubble is now transformed the
site will eventually house are
performing art space a vast transit hub
and four towers defining the new
Manhattan skyline monuments to the
ongoing struggle to recover from those
attacks a decade ago